저번 달에 돼지가 176평인데
800억에 실거래가 신고가 돼
있습니다 저기 청담동 명품거리보다 더
높은 가격으로
매입한 사례고
압구정로에서 제일 비싸게 매각한 그런
사례라고 보시면 될 것 같습니다
[음악]
제가 오늘은
압구정 로데오역에 나와 있습니다
갤러리 앞에 와 있는데 제가 여기에
왜 나와 있냐면 최근에 저번 달에이
인근에
매각 사례들이 나오고 있습니다
조금 뭔가 움직임이 포착이 돼 가지고
제가 좀 급하게 나왔는데 저번 달에
여기 하나 갤러리에서
압구정 로데오역
인근에
빌딩을 두 채를 매입했습니다 지금
제가 이따가 보여드릴 건데 그 압구정
로데오 가는 초입에 건물을 두 채를
매입했고 그리고 최근에 아직 그
등기부 등본이 넘어가진 않았는데 이쪽
대로변이죠 이쪽 압구정 로데오에
최고가의 실거래가 신고된게 있습니다
그 사례도 오늘 좀 같이 보여드리도록
하겠습니다 그 최고가의 팔린 거를
대지 평단가로 봤을 때 무려
4억 5천만 원입니다
압구정로 해서 최고 가격이고 심지어
도산대로의 거의 버금가는 가격으로
매입했는데
과연 어떤 건물이 그렇게 매각이
됐는지 한번 보도록 하겠습니다 가시죠
네 그래서 저기 뒤에 보이는 저 흰색
건물이 저번 달에 돼지가 176평인데
800억의 실거래가 신고가 돼
있습니다 전면이 되게 길어요 그래서
뭐 정확히 몇 미터인지 모르겠지만 한
25m에서 한 30m는 좀 안 될 것
같은데 전면이 굉장히
긴 그런 빌딩입니다 그리고 지금
3층짜리 규모인데 지하 1층에 지상
3층 정도 되는
규모의 빌딩입니다 그래서 일단이 건물
같은 경우에는
용도지역이 3종 일반주거지역이에요
여기가 압구정 로우인데 압구정로
지구단위 계획이 있어서 건물을 더
높게 올리거나
그러기는 좀 쉽진 않더라구요 그리고
이제 심의도 받아야 되는 부분도
있어서 지금이 상태가 어떻게 보면
최적의 상태라고 보여지는데 지금이
건물을 800억 대지 평당
4억 5천에
매입을 했습니다 이거는 저기 청담동
명품거리보다 더
높은 가격으로
매입한 사례고 압구정로에서 제일
비싸게 매각한 그런 사례라고 보시면
될 것 같습니다 지금 저쪽 안쪽으로
들어가면 하나가
매입한 건물 전체가 있는데 그것도
한번 좀 가서 보도록 하시죠
네 저는 지금 하나가
4월 달에 매입한 건물 앞에 와
있습니다 그래서 저기 뒤에 보이는
저흰 색깔 건물과 그 옆에 코너
건물을 같이 매입을 했습니다 그래서
지금 두 건물의 매매가격 합계는 무려
895억 원입니다이 건물을 매입한
이유를 좀 보니까 하나의 김
본부장님이 지금 이쪽이 두 건물을
mz세대들이 좋아하는 공간을 좀
만들겠다라는 기사를 좀 봤는데 지금
김 본부장님의 행보가 되게 좀 재밌는
거 같아요
요즘 좀 젊은 사람들이 좋아할 만한
그런 공간들을 좀 많이 만들려고
생각하시는 거 같고 그리고 최근에는
미국에 되게 유명한 버거인 5가이즈를
국내에 처음 들여왔습니다 그래서 아마
조만간에 오픈을 할 거 같은데 아마
mg 세대들이 굉장히 좋아할 만한
그런 임차 업종 아니면 이제 직접
운영하려는 그런 목적들이 있는 거
같습니다 그래서 하나 같은 경우에는
지금 나인원 한남에도
고메를 이제 운영 중이잖아요 그래서
거기도
워낙 핫한 업체들이 많이 들어왔기
때문에 지금이 두 건물에서도 좀 그런
업체들이 들어오지 않을까 이렇게
예상을 합니다 그리고 저 두 건물을
철거한 다음에 같이 신축할 그런
가능성도 좀 있어 보입니다
차라리 이렇게 좀 합칠 경우에는
대지가 거의 한 330평 정도
되거든요 그랬을 때 연면적도 상당히
나오기 때문에 두 건물을 멸실한
다음에
신축할 그런 가능성도 좀 있어
보입니다 올해 들어서 1월 달
2월달에 거래가 좀 많이 없었지만
최근에 거래량이 좀 살아나고 있고
저번 달 4월 달에 특히 이쪽 블록에
거래가 최고가 되고 있어서
뭔가 새로운 움직임이 좀 움직이고
있는 거 같아요 저도 이런 매각살에
보면서 아 뭔가 좀 시장이 움직이고
있구나 좀 이렇게 생각을 하고
있습니다
오늘 사례와 같이
시장은 굉장히 좀
빠르게 움직이고 있는 거 같고 우리
모르게 이렇게 좀 거래가 계속되고
있는 거 같아요
앞으로 지금이 두 건물뿐만 아니라
저기 압구정로에
4억 5천에
팔렸던 그 건물도 어떻게 변할지가
굉장히 궁금합니다 여기서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요 여러분들 제 영상이
즐거우셨다면
구독과 좋아요 눌러주시면
감사하겠습니다 감사합니다